okay so today we're looking at two of
them started with one last class and we
got introduced to a bunch of different
character is Socrates you probably
already knew about because you know he's
the name of the air above in the Western
Civ class from history class teacher of
Plato there's three other younger men
who are involved love in heaven antis of
Allah Marcus they're the ones who are
actually going to be doing more of the
talking in this this book or this
chapter and then last time we got the
truth of this guy certificates we talk
about his ideas and we talked a little
bit about the practical reasoning that
would come out of that the way of
approaching moral issues the way of
approaching life that would come out so
let's start with through Simmons because
while Caen and Anna Mantis are going to
be taking over by saying you know
Socrates I don't think you really answer
I think the problem that through Simic
has raised is a real problem and you
kind of gave him a song-and-dance if you
followed the arguments closely and it
takes a while to to study the art events
and to figure out exactly what's being
said but if he followed the arguments
closely when you were reading the
interplay between Socrates and through
Simitis you mean he had some moments
where you said wait a second here
her syndicates could have said this and
he could've answered Socrates you know
think about the the argument that they
had where Socrates from tourniquets is
saying you know the shepherd doesn't
take care of the sheep for the good of
the sheep he takes care of the shoes
because he's gonna eat this shoe same
thing with the rule is the rule but
Socrates you know is I'm talking about
good Shepherds and you know good ruler
isn't medicine all that sort of stuff
and he's kind of leaving something out
of this I mean there are a lot of people
out there who are practicing their craft
now they're doing it in kind of corrupt
way so as to attain things wait outside
they're crafting and they don't take
care of the people that they're
concerned with right this happens all
the time or they only take care of a
part of the people they're concerned you
know think about corruption in politics
politicians corrupt what are they doing
they're privileged a some members
probably just a few members of the
society they're supposed to be taken
care of against against the rest are
there corrupt politicians in your
experience from the New York area in the
Chicago area we'll probably have about
the same proportion
politicians are there doctors who take
advantage of their patients yeah I mean
ever you every so often if you watch the
news doesn't somebody got trouble
usually there's something sexual there's
often in terms of money right either
police officers who
yeah I mean let's not stay all of them
but Socrates is kind of talking as if
you know it's recipients is it well
anybody who's really concerned with an
art you know they never do anything like
that you could respond on juice images
as part and this is what Lacan and anime
artists are doing they're saying hey you
know you may have beat through Simitis
but that's because through Simitis
really wasn't ready for it he thought it
was but he couldn't stand up to hear our
visuals but maybe there's you know
there's there's more to the story than
this this is important to recognize if
you're looking at practical reasoning or
other people's moral theories and you
want to take them on and they're
strongest when you criticize somebody if
you want to say somebody's wrong you
want to actually look at all the ways in
which they might be right you can't just
say try to full of it you know and
dismiss them if you really want to do
practical reasoning well if somebody
else is up there through simha kisses
way of life really is the best way of
life then you know maybe we shouldn't be
reading Socrates and Aristotle maybe
this semester we ought to be reading a
lot more times hops which we're going to
be later and some you know some meet you
everything is about the will to power
and dominating each other we should read
people like that
I say you ready say you know you're
supposed to tell somebody about what you
actually did this week you're studying
and you learned about this through
Seneca scans if you're sending us who's
that
what's he like how would you
characterize
fundamentally a good guy
what's he what's he about I really think
it's the best thing
yeah that's one of his cheap points
justice is and then you know this is
debate what is that it was that meaning
physically stronger no a person who can
impose their no as power so in a
democracy who is the stronger the
Democrat the democratically elected
leadership in a tyranny tyranny means
one person rules and they're not ruling
for the good of everybody we usually
call that a dictatorship I think about
North Korea who's who's in charge there
who's a guy that they like to make fun
of on Saturday Night Live other comedy
shows he is kind of funny he's got some
quirks anybody know the dictator of
North Korea Kim Jong Il South Park cows
you know bashes it as well
they made that movie with the puppets
was it Team America yeah and they were
really dudes watching that
because they but but he gets to call the
shots this dad was in charge and now
he's in charge of the attorney and he's
one of those power so it King Kim
jong-il this is what happens in North
Korea he believes that he's a really
great actor among other things so if
you're in North Korea and you think his
acting isn't very good you probably
should keep your mouth shut
because otherwise you may be re-educated
and that's justice that's in the
interest of the stronger
that's just self-esteem right that's at
stake you know your self-esteem is kind
of that stiff - and I suppose if
somebody opposes power around you you've
all had that happen to one degree or
another how's that feel how do you feel
about yourself when you give in to
somebody yeah you feel demeaned another
word that we often use it that is
humiliated you are may feel lesser
alright somebody exert its power in
somebody treats you badly and then you
don't have any possible response do it
often and often you'll start to search
shrink it on yourself it will change New
York so you have justice of the interest
of the stronger what is the real value
of your sentence what's what's good what
didn't you know he doesn't actually
coming right out and saying this is the
good but if you were sitting across from
sir senator
this what would you say that that guy is
motivated by making himself better
better in one sense a better person who
you know helps old women across the busy
street you know might even moderate you
know new modern dad seem to be the
person that's trying to just get like a
lot of money and we have is like a
material type you're on the right track
well first Americans recognize as well
this is good
he thinks that power is a good power can
get you well well can get you power his
idea of power seems to be how are you
know certainly domination another way we
might think of them is he's obsessed
with winning not in a charleshayne way
we're here evaluate the losing becomes
winning and the world becomes very
confusing when you start listening to
Charlie Sheen doesn't and then the you
know it's unfortunate this is a
digression but Charlie Sheen is a really
smart guy but the parts are all jumbled
up and I would listen to some of the
things that he would say and they know
okay that that part makes sense and that
part actually seems to be pretty
insightful but then you put it all
together one big picture that's just
like you know colitis sir you can't
figure out what he's trying to say or
something cuz it's more consistent
through you know people like you're
sending us
I used to help out with the debate team
at my former school Hill State
University in a fairly minor way yeah I
came to realize very quickly talking
with the coach debate these days is no
longer about convincing anybody it's
about winning and people will bring up
all sorts of points in them nothing to
do with the subject if you really think
about it but you know they can score
points we can call these talking points
and this is what goes out a lot in
politics and this is what goes out a lot
in your ordinary day-to-day
conversations you all know people like
precipitous who want to win and they're
not particularly concerned whether the
position that they put forth is actually
true or not they just want to win they
want to dominate right can you all
relate to this maybe a few of you are
like that you know I was like that when
I was your age I was like that for a
very long time it's kind of horrible
because he has a very self-centered way
about what he does as oppose the most
people kind of generally have a
consideration about yeah we you know
needs this and what people need than one
sorry - what yeah let me take there's
something to societal yeah you're right
most people that we encounter seem to
have some consideration for other people
but you know pushing them put them in
tense situations and today do they stick
to that some of them a lot of them turn
out to be
kind of mean nice is not the same thing
as good or just you know truthful or
anything like that
nice works when you're not in a conflict
but you've got a lot of society after
this well you look at our society and
explore it says oh I'm in competition
you know everybody wants to win but you
still see people house we know the team
made up back to the tap absolutely so
you're right a minute they make up a
diamond there or whatever it is the
ability to sometimes yeah so but he's
not really going to say okay let me help
y'all yeah it's like are your weakens
they died but now that's when I was a
kid did Co the Bears was a player and he
was mean as health and he was greatly
admired because he was sacked guys break
any didn't talk about that you know just
trying to hurt people then as I was in
college got Richard white actually long
one he was sort of the model of the guy
that you're talking about he was
actually on a preacher too and so you
know he cackled guys and he was he was a
huge linebacker and he would tackle guys
money so there's there's really two
sides to I remember during this last
Super Bowl the Steelers are known as a
dirty plain team you know Packers are
less
just getting outraged because you know
the Steelers were playing dirty because
that's what they do you know you if
people are like for some minutes it's
kind of silly to expect them to be nice
to be criticism so let's think about the
practical reasoning that's involved when
you're dealing with a perspective like
that true semanas what is practical
reasoning concerns this is this is
permanent views so there's certain
things that are that are good right
every perspective that you can look at
value something every one of you has a
bunch of things that you value not just
goods but also how good are arranged so
if you're through Civic s having certain
virtues like say being courteous that
would only be valuable insofar as it
brings you these things there's a way
that goods are arranged in terms of each
other and it comes down to being
courteous or enjoying power and wealth
one gets prioritized and the other one
gets put down there are some people who
had changed right there are some people
who would be courteous even though it
means that they have to pass up the
opportunity to make some money or
nominate somebody so you're probably
like that I hope we don't have some
people like that word a lot of trouble
so there's goods and there's there's
arrangements or priorities and then
there is also going to be a view
these are these are all things that are
involved with when you're carrying a
practical reason I mean you can you can
think of something some types of
practical reason that are very simple
I'm hungry if I don't eat I will starve
and if I start will die I don't want to
die hunger is a sign of starving the you
know conclusion I'd better eat something
that's that's you know practical reason
it doesn't involve anybody else but when
we're dealing with you know people like
through some I guess it doesn't bother
so we talk about this a little bit last
class let's say you have opportunities
let's say you do see the world the way
through something it's does so you you
have a capacity to participate in
politics or business or any of the other
things that you know your college career
is preparing for medicine or criminal
justice right the ability to do things
in society that people care enough how
do you reason about things what what
should you be pursuing if you're through
semanas
if your certificates you just want to
take advantage of every opportunity and
you know whether whether it's a an
opportunity that involves helping people
explain to progressive in selfies and
take care yet no I'm gonna progress
myself before somebody else yes
more practically you have to tell look
at how often do you get that opportunity
as opposed to help me do somebody else
so it's a once in a lifetime opportunity
you never gonna get the chance I think
anybody is really coming to kind of
gonna kind of show you to want to take
advantage of that opportunity meaning
something might not get another chance
there are moments of crisis the Greek
word for crisis means like the decision
and that's actually give a good point
again is a little bit with that ration
of looking at head when you have to when
you have to use ethics are those moments
where if you don't act now you could
lose out so there's a temptation to get
in and walking times or thinking it's a
short-circuit because all of you have
some way I don't you do practically
reason one of the questions that we're
going to try to get you to work with in
this class is thinking about are my ways
of practically reasoning now as I come
into this class are they good enough
where do I have to you know if he had
some more schools I mean you may find
yourself being somebody like to through
semanas like I said I was it I was
obsessed with with winning
great debater and I actually heard a lot
of people in process because I was so
vehement and I just convinced that you
know I've managed to advance myself and
I was actually the truth and then when I
look at that I see here's an example of
practical reason power is good X will
lead me to power what it was the natural
conclusion to pursue alright we can make
this more complicated we could say power
is good family relations are also good
you know love within a family unit is
good law and fin and you know and power
may not be compatible powers are greater
good person power or pseudonymous that's
the world that there's so much miss
Withers
that's if you actually have a chance of
being outside what if we don't reject
about this last what wouldn't you better
do that but what is practical reason I
tell you this is this is really right
this means that everybody gets to charge
is kind of bastard right
greedy exploited to have how did that
get up there on top well by you know
being better than the other exploiters
by beating them there's this expression
you know politics is war by other means
and it can be office politics sexual
politics it doesn't have to be like
twirl so if somebody else has got the
better you're not gonna be able to
wiggle your way up wonder what did you
better do we want to be
become more powerful let's say there's
not a possibility though but that would
be something your practical reasoning
would have to actually part of the
through your through civic empathy
assessing the situation do you add you
have a chance of becoming more powerful
let's say you figured out you can't do
never wouldn't do everything that they
want to take their desires and they
become your desires nor even said
something that's actually something
beyond these are actually two point
compatible if you are graphically reason
if you're thinking about what do I need
to do how do I need to arrange my life
and there's no way grow you can actually
gain power and become one of the elite
that gets to rule or at least even get
in the game and maybe fight it out then
you do have to give in and the desires
are the powerful the interests of the
powerful is strong those has become your
interest so if they want you to work
20-hour days you have to start liking
coding hour days or also you're going to
you know have some real cognitive
dissonance and like you said you have to
learn how to deal how to deal with it
that can become a value that can that's
something that we actually talk about as
it is a good thing right learning how to
deal with it but sometimes learning how
to deal with things is adapting yourself
to a really bad situation it may not be
the best thing to do but that's what
that kind of practical reasoning leading
to sort of closing off the you know
opportunities in your life if you tell
yourself things will never get any
better than this then it actually
becomes rational it doesn't to say
well better you know if follow me to eat
his oatmeal better to learn a level that
would be helped me they did because
forget practical reason I eat it because
I'm a man who was over 40 and I'm
supposed to watch my heart and blah blah
blah blah I don't feel it's good for
that so I'd say eat it so he make your
sausage men do things they don't want
so that's through some I guess and
that's a position then we can call it go
ISM make it futile ISM and that's that's
a moral theory that's a way of practical
reasoning yes I feel like it's taking
things too hypothetical like he's
pushing it it's a life that's a
situation that would never happen cuz
he's talking about the state and lying
yeah a man being just persons I just I
feel like it's the psyche
being completely justice yeah because I
mean every politician is just in some
ways otherwise they've been you know we
can't kick him out right away but you're
right there's always some injustice
going on there's there's some privileges
of somebody's position over over another
the kind of political system that we
have where we elect candidates
somebody's not going to be happy right
no matter what happens it may be a very
small minority but that's not happy but
guaranteed somebody's interests are
going to be interfered with and that
could be unjust so you're right if we're
thinking in terms of pure justice or
pure injustice these are hypotheticals
and we're going to look at another
hypothetical a little bit later but
these hypotheticals can be very useful
to thinking about real life issues we
don't say that we're going to do things
like that so let's think now about this
guy Bob bobbin says Socrates I think
that your Simek is they actually have
something I don't believe what he's
saying but I want to see you engage with
his argument and I wants to do it better
and Robin starts up at Wapping are over
three kinds of goods so this is
introducing a new idea for us in in
ethics about goods and the way that we
relate that to each other and welkins
talks about goods that are valued or see
other things and he talks about Goods
valued for their whole state and for
other things which they produce and then
he talks about its values for their
welcome make sure they're making a
handout with this sort of stuff for them
because I realized that it might be
useful I know it's useful for me to like
lay things out kind of a chart form so
I'm greeting so there are some quotes
that we value they're good things but we
don't feel that they're good you know in
the know themselves we don't pursue them
we don't say like going to the doctor he
uses that as an example you know do we
does anybody here really enjoy going to
the doctor I mean you know there are
some people there are some people go to
the doctor because they have no human
contact with anybody else's so they like
that that's not most of us right we go
to the doctor because we're sick or
because somebody tells us of the
everyone both of you who were athletes
you had to check those right you have to
get checkups more often any of you who
have any of you have ever been like
injured we needed physical therapy what
was that what was the physical therapy
that's terrible yeah that's that so
everybody says I've done a little bit of
it and I hated it but it was a good
thing wasn't it right in the end because
that's a good way to put it it's leading
to some other hand we don't value it for
its own sake if you did there'd be
something wrong with you
you'd have your
that's a priority big stuff so what are
some things we put in there for making
money
what's money good for everything come by
sometime give their love they may not be
the best kind of love certainly buys new
opportunities but what's it like making
money why do people spend the time
making money is it for the sake of money
yeah money is power money can money can
bring you power there's one one side
there's there's a famous author for gays
who has this great line money is the
future tense money is that which is
going to come you can use it to get this
where were you yeah and then they acted
actually making money money by itself is
not valuable in itself it's valuable so
that you can do all these other things
the act of making money that's even more
than just you know having the money
making money what do we call that work
right do do you think that most people
love their jobs is that your experience
but it depends what state you are those
who like us we need this so much yeah
summer jobs to you you may actually do a
summer job and they'd be fine
whoa I really like this thing but it's
the activity that you like that it's
money you're making money it's great
that the money comes with but what are
most jobs in your experience you guys
have all worked core jobs or just say
you know the money's there so you just
do it and tough it out something better
girl yeah
and again deciding to tough it out until
something better comes along something
that has a that's more appealing to you
that it has to offer you
that's practically reasoning this money
even getting a summer job why do you
need to get a summer job need some money
or he called the gymnastics gymnastics
in degrees gymnastics doesn't mean
getting out of you know rings or things
like that those lines it meant all
physical exercise given hasta que men's
athletic exercise
for its own sake don't thank you guys
for grasses in here there are there are
parts of what you do that you really
enjoy you probably couldn't perform at
the level that you do this school is
very demanding because another unless
you actually enjoy not just certain
helmets for the whole game of basketball
soccer what are they do we have any on
the outfits in here
well they're swimming it's what I made
oh well that's very something half-day
what else anybody else football yeah
that's also we had a long way to do you
don't want right your coach makes you do
it why does it coach make it to get
better right there's some goal and the
whole setting that's kind of that you're
healthier way healthier than I am there
could be honor that comes with it
there could be enjoyment I mean some of
the things that you do you can only
enjoy them when you get good at them
right setting a really good pic knowing
exactly what to do that good slide
tackle that doesn't get you a yellow car
scoring using your body than the most
efficient man in the swimming
those bringing fighters but you don't
have that just in the exercise the
exercise leads to those things what are
some Goods valued for their own sake he
talks about performance and there's lots
of ways in which we enjoy things I was
talking before I came into class about
an interesting experience yesterday I
went to a French restaurant for the very
first time because a whole bunch of
events going at the culinary dealing
with sustainability Iook I'm a
philosopher and I do a fix and the main
speaker is is a philosopher so I was
there today you know and schmooze a bit
and one of the perks was I got to go to
that French restaurant and you know we a
lot of courses and it's very formal and
I've never experienced that's why I
wasn't sure which you know my hands but
in general it was a pretty enjoyable
thing to do the only thing that actually
distracted me from the enjoyment was
thinking about how much class prep I
need to get the hell
that's enjoy did is there any other
purpose and then I might am I in the
French restaurant enjoying something
because it's leading me to some greater
good oh you enjoy it for its own sake if
you were saying you know if I would say
I'm there to get power and say doctor
said that you're a dummy just sit down
and enjoy it right does anybody here
play play video games because it's
making you a better citizen it's
prove your lion that some other way you
know unless there like some sort of
hokey educational games you're probably
crazy for doing that you're playing
video games video games are fine right
why do we watch movies I know some of
you watch movies in your other classes
you may be disappointed that I'm not
showing it would be this semester you
could be watching a movie for an
educational purpose why do you watch
movies mostly entertainment it could be
a way of socializing so there aren't
goods that we value just for their own
sake and then there's some Goods and
this is where it's really interesting
there's some goods that we value for
their own sake but we also value because
they produce other goods why princes
help if you're healthy you can do a lot
of things right it opens up doors for
you I'll give you an example I have been
in this sort of shape for really since
I've been about thirty yeah I'm not
happy with it but I don't seem to find
the time to get back into shape and when
I was your age
yeah I mean all the way through my 20s I
was actually in amazing shape they
should work out three hours a day doing
endurance lifting
we'll wait in the back of the pack all
these sorts of things right rain and
shine you know big girl tough guy and
all that I am associated with the
philosophical Society of Nepal Nepali no
where is that that's north of India way
up in the mountains they actually at one
point this was several years ago they
they said why don't you come to Nepal
and give talk about now that would've
been a pretty good opportunity wouldn't
it we see the whole different Kingdom
Alliance money
resume meet some interesting people I
said no you know why look at me do you
think I would be doing well huffing and
puffing going up and down mountains
pretty trippy alright but health is a
good that we desire for its own sake and
because it makes opportunities for other
things are there any other things like
that way to give you some examples
polish although some of some of us may
put it over here but knowledge if you
really do enjoy knowing things you like
knowing things because you can do
something with your knowledge right you
know for instance you're you're pre-med
right so there's a whole bunch of things
you have to
and they add I mean that death plants
played solvent most colleges has a
pretty high failure rate because people
have to memorize so much you might like
it but why are you doing it it's not
just you're not learning and just for
the sake of learning anatomy because if
you're like opening up the block and
seeing along the balls okay what's it
for
it's gonna make you a doctor who
actually knows what he's doing
who can identify things I kind of want
that in the doctor so that's that's a
good that's okay so where's justice yes
that's where we get two different ideas
about what's different theories of
practical reason yes Socrates where did
you place justice where does Socrates
place justice yeah good value for own
sake for very good yeah
justice Socrates says is something good
in its own sake and it also produces a
positive x if people treat each other
the right way that creates a society in
which people will for instance take
risks do innovation develop right not
come out you know not come into the
classroom all screwed up either totally
unjust society many of our people may
not even be editable because the man
doesn't such you know terrible
psychological problems where do most
people place
you know masterlock yeah most people
pretty involved in it and see justice
yeah it's not something that's actually
good just something that leads you to
other things like honor reputation power
there's actually a great story in
another Greek author Herodotus about
this guy that becomes the king of the
kingdom because he's a really just judge
and he's only just because he wants
people to think that it's a really good
guy and that he put him in charge of
things through the rule everything you
know the best way taking care of
everybody's interests what do you think
he doesn't get some powers yeah exactly
the mass comes a lot he says that I've
got all of you know anything is the
worst tyrant of all that's someone who
values justice for the sake of something
else why do the rest of us value justice
for the cities where there is something
to this let's think about speed limits
how many of you breaks people how many
of you feel that if you're on the
interstate and somebody is not driving
at least ten over they want not to be in
the left lane
how many do get angry because they're
not breaking the law there's something
wrong with us isn't there I mean at
least in this respect that's justice
following the law is justice why do we
do it
I mean why wires to be little bits in
place because because 50 driving 55 is
good in and of itself safety yeah who is
who safety everyone's I mean it's other
drivers
other people your honor the state has
also concerned with your own safety if
you're driving too fast at whispering
accident
although the cars that we do I think
we're pretty fast without you know
losing control sometimes to be driving
along I'm going 85 90 and I don't
realize because there's something to go
along with that the DMV and look it says
you have to go along with traffic so
traffic's going like 90 miles an hour
have any of you ever tried to use it as
a oh yeah
you can you can actually even say I was
following along with a cop they're gonna
say you broke the law but you're right
now if you're driving it I don't know
about New York's I don't drive in New
York City but if I'm driving in Chicago
and traffic is moving it's moving at 85
and if you were to drive 55 which is the
speed limit most its place you caused
the accident but still if they pull you
over
now there is something to justice being
valuable under the sake of other things
many of us look at those are the laws or
things like that as just something that
we have to do so that we don't get in
trouble right and this brings us to
walkins idea about the origin of justice
and this is where we see some really
interesting practical reasoning and
we're also going to see one of the moral
theories that we're going to look at
this semester of rear-ends test for the
first time
it's called contract arianism which is a
very long fancy name for saying that
we're basically ego nests are basically
self-centered and we enter into
something like a social contract so that
we don't hurt each other so that we can
be assured of having the things that you
want so that's we can carry out the
practical reasoning yeah the priming
good areas don't violate this local
contract because if you do you're
screwing it up for everybody else so you
can ask yourself so that any case is
what I'm doing with that violated some
contract if yes then it's the wrong
thing to do not wrong in and of itself
which is wrong because it violates the
social country welcome talks about most
people's views of injustice and this is
kind of interesting because injustice in
a way it is a good thing it leads to
good things
or who what's it for the person who
commits it if I can you know she's a
traffic example I can try the one with
the speed limit you know and see the no
accidents to happen or anything like
that I get where I'm going burger it's
good for me right now if your dog
happens to be in the road that's not
good you know visit might you know kind
of play might my fiancee if she sees
like you know a squirrel or you know a
possum or something official swerve by I
will for a daughter yeah but in fun 955
I'm not that last word because you know
it's an animal's life versus the
possibility of a catastrophic accident
I've actually get fourth year of my life
killed for three at one time I was
driving 65 a night and I didn't think
about this that I thought about this
afterwards I did the right thing I just
kept going I didn't try to avoid them or
anything just kept going right now if
that's the case your dog runs out of
road and I'm driving you know 65 in a 45
your dogs probably gonna get it
that's bad for you isn't it if I let's
say they take something else if I am a
judge and I take bribes
why am I taking them privately if I take
Brian's I'm making money maybe been
making friends when taking bribes right
bad for pretty much everybody else
doesn't it's not just bad for the person
whose case get settled
wrong it's bad for society in general
my justice justice is good yeah I've
heard that one now he doesn't in that
pants that she doesn't come out and say
that it necessarily hurt so we were
saying that the judges that that's an
example that's not in the text that's
one of the just man is unjust then there
would be no walkin doesn't saying that
he thinks that just man just just kind
of stupid but didn't know that's the
unjust the unjust man wants to appear
just because that allows him to get by
but he isn't actually just we're going
to contrast them no we'll come to that
justice is is or anyone else what it's
bad for you bad for you
Isaak wended what could be bad follow
the rules can't take advantage of
everybody else and get what you want and
need to think about this in terms of
getting like whole society or a business
partnership you could think of this in
terms of marriage all right some people
are exploitative with respect to their
spouses or any sort of thing like that
you can think of this in terms of
friendships we have in terms of this
families this has a lot of application
so why do we why does society say it's
better to be just well because the band
that you might encounter at the hands of
other people outweighs the good in being
unjust to you you would like to be have
just given the opportunity every single
one in you just like me would take
advantage of other people and Bob the
only reason you don't want to do it is
because you're afraid of what the other
people you know if we said okay
everything goes and yeah it'd be nice
for you a little bit but you'd also have
all these other people out there all
your classmates transfer you over and
you would get hurt more the process the
things that you want wouldn't be
realized
so you practically reason than you say
and actually all of us say together
let's be just I mean we won't get as you
know as much fun but I mean at least we
won't be hurting each other and then I
can live in my little house in peace and
enjoy my little stuff and you
your little house of peace and that will
be the way it goes I won't be able to
you know build a big mansion and make
all of you my servants but that's
because I don't want to take the chance
of you doing that to me now notice
that's not valuing justice for its own
sake that's saying justice is only good
because it leads to the borders the
capacity to enjoy the candidates you
want that's the way a lot of people do
see justice isn't it why follow the
rules if we didn't follow the rules
it would hurt us yeah what's it like
just as though it's not really bad for
us that helps us out at least - it gives
us not opportunities and being unjust
isn't the only bad because it's bad for
the people it's bad because they can't
hurt us as well Curtis - well if I'm
speeding and I had a trade I didn't may
not hurt anyone else but I'm still gonna
hurt myself yeah but I could go my whole
life speeding and not hurt anybody else
sure now where that doesn't make me
justice because it doesn't hurt any well
it's like where do you see chances are
of hurting someone else when you're not
where you see both pretty low but it's
still just to do it not because it's bad
from the people but it's because it's
bad for yourself yeah you're right maybe
maybe there's some problems with this
this model walking himself doesn't
actually - he wants to hear Socrates
defend justice for its own sake but the
problem is most people aren't defending
it for its own sake they're defending it
for the goods that that it brings you
and a lot of people do have the view
that you know everybody is really just
out to get everybody else just to take
their fair share and or if they can get
this
this is a view of human nature that's
something to share this is this egoism
about this part is contract areas let's
move on to the next idea this is gonna
bring us to an exercise where I think
you'll have a lot to say
Glaucon says let's let's think about
this and let's make it a hypothetical
let's think about the absolutely unjust
man and the absolutely justice and the
absolutely just man doesn't just want to
appear justice he wants to actually be
just and even if he doesn't appear just
that's okay with him you know I'll give
you an example of that that's not in the
text there was a monk and I forget which
which is some saint they should read the
lives of the saints and I remember
coming across this story and he's in the
monastery and he took care of this woman
in town and she she got knocked off by
somebody else and she blamed it on the
monk and everybody thought that he did
it and he just kept his mouth shut
because he thought the consequences
would be worse for her if he could take
he could take he could take the
innovation where he said it was not just
nice it was it was going anonymous and
she said he had stuff about to continue
to do that and people aren't our kind of
somebody else'll offers an opportunity
to do that yeah actually she then gave
him the kid she skipped town
and she said here is your kid this kind
of knows it's not his kid everybody's
treating him like like a dirt bag
because they think that you know he's
aplomb he's supposed to be a man of the
cloth that he's he's off you know
getting women pregnant he takes care of
the kid raises the kid those are just
yeah those are good things only there is
wasn't hesitant to begin with that's an
insane example of somebody who appears
to be on chops what is actually jealous
Malkin makes it even more you know stark
here you know the unjust manner that the
just man that was really unjust who
appears to be unjust people punish them
they excursion that's your skin Brandi
he loses everything will he still be
just if he only loves justice for the
sake of all the things then he's a dummy
for remaining just he's a poor cracker
reasoner what about the unjust man to be
a really interesting point Watkins says
the height of injustice it's not just to
be unjust it's to be unjust
well appearing to be justice because
what do you do to screw up people's
perceptions you screw up the very
perception of right and wrong it's sort
of like a
McCants corruption in the middle what
appears to be just ya the unjust man he
says let's keep them all the advantages
because a smooth talker he is courageous
so you know when he's confronted with
something he's bold enough to say that I
wasn't me I didn't do that he's got
friends he's got money he's got
influence because he's not just he's
gonna have power as well whose wife is
him
yeah so most people it seems that the
unjust man's life this is better
Socrates is still actually could say
that just man's life is better we'll
talk about why later it's kind of
paradoxical isn't it
I mean if you think that justice is only
good because it leads to other things
like power or reputation being you know
getting along with people then this is
going to you know make you say I don't
want justice the the unjust to prosper
in our society the wicked to get away
with their crimes so maybe you really
want to be wicked maybe you're a sucker
for being nice for being just for doing
the right thing that's the problem and
now you bring up something really
interesting this is what more we're
going to do sort of finish it well you
all grown apart the ring of gaijin's
right what is this this story that guy
Jesus great not the ring unlikely of JRR
tolkien bears some similarities to it
doesn't it what is this ring advantages
yeah
exactly and now because of this rig it
doesn't necessarily have to be arranged
through their science fiction stories
where somebody hasn't watched that stops
time I actually give you a little short
of one of those things but there is a
whole movie about this than they have at
the golden watch what do you think the
very first thing is that he does so good
once you realize do you steal something
and then the next thing is he sees a
girl playing volleyball sort of takes
her time
that's her there are there is you know
this story's about an invisible man you
know people turning invisible and what's
the first thing they do to sneak into
the locker they do injustice right why
do they put because there's no
possibility of getting caught and
punished so it could be stopping time
that they've ever seen the movie
Groundhog Day
now you remember there's there's the
character gross Bill Murray's character
at first he's kind of a jerk and he
doesn't like candy the devil then he
falls in love with her later but he
eventually he does the right thing and
then it breaks the spell and all that
there's a point halfway through the
movie where he's just messing people
because he knows hey whatever happens I
can I can act whatever I wanted today
and tomorrow I'm gonna wake up and be
right here and so he screws around with
people because he's got power now you
can you know very uneven very easily
relate to this right so he asked
yourself